we're saving the city all the women were
in charge and like running things and
they were cool but they're also messy
like everybody has different layers
shailene woodley is Tris the leader of
the divergence her strongest allies they
escape Wald in Chicago is zoe kravitz
Christina we have to make a stand take
over from me Naomi Watts is the
self-appointed leader fighting from the
inside
joined by Octavia Spencer Joanna it does
help that the women are pretty badass
can I say that who are the women that
are the strong role models in your
everyday lives it's funny because we
think which is great because you know
you don't understand what you're seeing
when you're a kid you know Naomi is a
mom herself with fiance Liev Schreiber
she has two sons aged seven and eight I
did love the Instagram that you put up
of your kids sitting around reading
Harry Potter do they know the divergent
series yet are they getting not yet it's
a little scary yeah I was gonna say do
they even really know what you do or do
they do now they get totally there was a
long time where they just thought mommy
and daddy went to work in a trailer